what's going on there reject nation koi's back
with us after missing episode five did you like
episode five a lot of crying all right and
it wasn't here on camera you you robbed the
audience of that reaction at home i just kept it
to myself we're at the finale of moon night people
thank you guys so much for joining us on this
journey it's been amazing i'm sad to see it end
right now let's see what's in store let's see
if it sticks the landing guys full length watch
along as we see with the time code are available
for our super sexy rejects at our patreon page
thank you all for joining us especially
for the moon night reactions means a lot
follow koi on the socials tick tock and youtube
he's posting all the time it's annoying but it's
good also leave a like that would probably be the
most beneficial thing you can do for this video
today thank you guys so much and thank you to
the boys at prepper for helping us edit down the
highlights for moonlight thank you john for being
john john oh thanks for being greg let's do it
i'm sorry i'd have to be this
way mark specter stephen graham
whoever else might be in there
they keep hinting man yeah
oh no oh no who wants to heal the world
i don't need to show you my papers
wait i am the goddess to wet it oh
what you should listen to the goddess
perhaps it's mark who's telling
you to stop what the hell is this
huh he's dead and i'm talking to you
through dead people right it's time to go
no one's questioning who this person is
this is the face of a good woman this
is like a very small group of people
someone is trying to release
amit i don't trust her why carl
i mean mark tried to tell you clearly
leave with the gods hidden from mankind
let's break them all god fights
this is all so avoidable nice i love
a good off-camera fight choreography
oh here it goes oh we're going big oh that's cool
wow
my name is come on do some marvel comedy
whom do i owe my gratitude your humble
disciple my goddess to whom you owe nothing
your scales lack balance oh oh i had hoped
my penance might correct my imbalance
but i see now that's impossible
you are the avatar that i need
serve me and you will find peace
oh yeah do not let the pain of the past control
you it's like the theme of this whole show
oh
i am in need of an avatar would you layla
no
time has been cruel to you indeed i cannot
allow you to proceed there's someone else here
right maybe it was that random person on our team
you don't need him anymore mark so
i get to go on to eternal peace and
he just stays lost in the sand forever
i'm not good with that think about this
summon the cab lift i'm jake lockley just pulls up
looking pretty rough man huh way back then we
were so young you saved me i survived because i
knew i wasn't alone you're always there alive full
of hope and i tried to protect that and i failed
i couldn't protect you oh no man you didn't
abandon me and all of it although that field
back there was looking there it's looking pretty
good there's no way now i'm gonna abandon you
oh buddy we're the only real superpower
wow that was so sweet
yes
stephen
it's incredible these are
two different people to me
you came back the hell's wrong with you well i
did a whole little speech there oh kiss him kiss
god fight
cool
oh
no it's gotta be the both here osiris you older
resurrection
oh nice here we go haven't seen the moon
knight sued and truly moving in a while
i knew you would miss me taylor turned
you down didn't she amit has been freed
mark spector i need your help
uh just curious about something
how's this whole new arrangement gonna work then
even grant i was not speaking to you how's this
deal gonna work you would negotiate now i
would release you both you'll have my work
how the heck are we gonna get to cairo you
forget little world i am still the god of
the night sky oh all right you know what
i think you can take this one mark idiot
oh god damn it you changed your mind i would
be delighted to accept you as my avatar
your father was going to be over the moon when he
is my father yes i met him but i
took him to the field of wreath
i'm doing this or what i have a fabulous costume
they're seeing all kinds
of things lately over there
holy whoa perhaps judge everyone
oh that's pretty terrifying actually damn
how do you find a giant alligator god
cool i love it she looks
great damn harold got slighted
awesome
oh
wow
how did you get back wow you
look amazing what are you wearing
really jazzed about showing
you these new skill sets
oh man down
there's the shot
oh nice
it's like a fight game yeah swapped out
baby girl those people are getting judged so hard
i feel so bad about my life souls are triple
condemned egyptian super hero i am hell yeah
it's like a ghostbusters stream whoa
get up jake
wow
that's a hell of a shot wow
no chance mate jake lockley has entered the game
grab my hands we can start the spell now
we cannot take the chance
that amit finds a way out
she will kill again i sound
just like her you want them dead
hmm do it yourself we're rushing a little bit
now yeah one episode left the finale rushing
no
what if we disagree doc oh it wasn't
what if we believe something different oh
yeah you see that don't you oh yeah
i see it i see it why am i bleeding
well it is tempting to accept your diagnosis
doc we'd rather go save the world like
dude mid-sentence accent swishing holy
[__] hmm i can't believe it worked
i can't believe you live in this freaking mess
what
feelings
processing oh boy
the fact that we're all talking right now is a
good sign yeah soak it in just absorb it are we
going to get a post-credits scene i just want him
driving a cab i think the way of handling jake is
exactly what i want that's what i've been saying
is like just keep teasing him and then bring it
for the next season but like keep it ominous and
[__] you and focus on these two mm-hmm and then
this is another yeah make it really distinguished
yeah maybe we'll get him in a post-credits team
captain america are they gonna make him spanish
actually oh that's cool that would totally work
knocked out man
makes me so happy
mark spector truly believed
that after he and i parted ways
i wanted his wife to be my avatar and he
has no idea how troubled he truly is oh no
he's a limbo driver instead of a
cab driver meet my friend jay clarke
oh so conscious like using him
but not letting mark in on it
yeah so he's the true assassin mercenary like
all controlling he doesn't even need a suit up
nope he takes them out as a cabbie limo driver and
i like that she was in the suit because he didn't
need to suit up that's cool too like because they
changed steven grant to be like this british guy
who's not a billionaire and then to change jake
lockley from like new york cabby driver to i don't
know honoring oscar isaac's roots a little bit
more so why did the the randomly have an accent a
couple times in the in the psych ward to throw us
off dude that wasn't him that was i think that was
purposely done for the scenes i said it i said
it wasn't maybe i don't know maybe i'm wrong
maybe he actually hasn't accepted speak spanish
all right well i was thinking was that they were
just doing that to throw us off yeah because
that's what i thought like to really distinguish
better especially when he's like switching
in and out of accents in a particular scene
because it sounds like mark has like a chicago
accent and it just comes out a little bit more
an extra enunciation of the of the yeah that's
one thing i chalked it up too but i also thought
i was wrong too but it would also make sense
for something like that to come out in a more
drugged up state yeah i get boston when i drink
yeah yeah i said no i thought that that's okay
yeah it's just like when you're a little bit
more uh uninhibited you know that'll come out
of your subconscious no it was a mistake on oscar
isaacs yeah no he's too much he's messy with his
acting if i think of anything too much credit if i
have one complaint it's oscar isaac and his messy
vocal work this whole episode was great other than
oscar isaac's acting yeah you really threw me yeah
if we could just redo this but like cast somebody
else pedro pascal it's a weird feeling when my
favorite moments that's not my favorite moment but
it's definitely like probably my favorite moment
yeah well it's not even like truly opposed critics
it's kind of the ending like in its own way it's
it's less of a post-credit than most like it's an
actual it's key to the story definitely in a way
that i don't think post-credit scenes generally
are they usually set up something as opposed to
this which concludes something show us what's
up something they're going to go around hit
manny people yeah yeah i hope australia comes
back all right let's discuss this show people
chat all right guys we got microphones yeah
because we got a podcast where this goes up
so i was like hey let's let's mic up let's be
professionals it's not gonna be any different
it's gonna really improve the quality of
our conversation yeah i feel much more
entitled to just so much more like just a drastic
change from okay audio to drastically better audio
this feels good in my eardrums just a massive
switch 4k now people will never be able to
go back to the old audio dolby sound um so
this uh this episode really showed us that
they're getting all their diversity
out of the way with one character here
he's got every uh an ethnicity and nationality
within him he's got a span latino guy a jewish guy
and then jefferson british
guy yeah that sounds good
you know what we haven't seen a lot of
british superheroes uh so look we talked
a little bit while i was prepping some uh
footage and i was taking longer than usual
and so we're gonna have to naturally regurgitate
some of those conversations uh not a lot we're
gonna talk for like five minutes about it but
hey john yes why don't you kick us off with
your thoughts on what you thought about the moon
night finale be honest that's well that's required
absolutely the moon night finale i thought was
pretty decent i i liked it i had a good time i
really enjoyed the imagination i enjoyed some
of the crazy circumstances that came to pass
uh i do feel like this could have easily been
a couple episodes worth of material especially
coming out of the last episode that reached
such wonderful depths and heights of character
exploration felt like that stuff definitely had
to be fast-tracked in this episode um so yeah it
left me wanting some things but i had a great time
so it's not like a slam dunk of an ending but you
know i mean it it got there i would definitely
watch more i would be thrilled to return to and
expand this world but but yeah it feels maybe
a little bit limited from this vantage point
koi i thought we got a lot of the things we've
been seeking but i do think we got them very
quickly i would have loved another episode in
the field of reads and finding out what it was
like for mark spector to enjoy peace what his
experience of peace would even be beyond that
one beautiful shot where it looked like they
let oscar go to the spa but i also think there
was a beautiful moment between the brothers that
could have been earned a little more by pushing it
now obviously they have a format of you know six
episodes at marvel but i think the flexibility of
letting the scripts and the story they're telling
breathe and let it be seven let it be eight
i think what marvel the way marvel can improve is
by letting that flex you should tell the story in
the amount of time the story takes to tell not
in a certain allocated amount of episodes you
shape your story around i think that's kind of
backwards the way they're doing it right now
and i think this episode was the first time in the
moon night series i felt that in all of the marvel
series i felt a little bit of hurry up and wait
except loki i think loki is the one that i thought
the pacing stayed consistent throughout and as
such has my favorite marvel finale and as such is
personally my favorite marvel show because it has
six episodes that all feel justified whereas moon
knight i said if it stuck to landing was gonna
be my new favorite marvel show it's very good i
really really enjoyed it but i think loki is a
stronger arc and i do think if moon knight had
been perhaps seven had been um you know more in
the psychology at the finale and a little bit more
payoff it could have taken that number one spot
and as it stands now i think it's my number two
really enjoyed the finale uh
but i i did feel some wanting
yeah yeah i i i'd echo everything you
guys said i think i would say i liked it
a little bit less than you guys because i'm
just trying to push buttons in the comments
marvel hater now i just want people this is the
captain marvel movies you can't talk like that
engage in the comments if you're
listening on the only the podcast
you can't see what i'm doing they're
uh no i i would say that this episode had some of
the coolest moments that i've seen in the entire
series they're like they're the fighting while not
long there's not one really truly long fight scene
in any of these episodes is there oh they're
all brief everything's brief this one he got
two fight scenes effectively i thought that
was very creative because they distinguished
the fighting between mr knight and moon knight
very well and especially jake lockley he was all
so that must have been jake was that jake in the
first episode i think so and i also think it was
jake obviously in that one time they were both
like what was that but i think there's probably
if you re-watch it a couple episodes where
the bloodbath means it was jake i think we saw
jake probably more than we think we did probably
probably there's going to be a lot of people doing
videos about that racking hundreds of
thousands of views on them um and so
yeah that i i think that some of the fighting
was some of the coolest we've gotten i actually
was really worried once i saw massive
ahmed like growing ahmed was like oh
crap i was like my first thought and then as it
progressed i actually thought it was really cool
cage you fight it was kaiju does
how do you say it george takei
george occasions fight uh yeah i thought that
was a really cool fight um i mean it wasn't like
the coolest fight ever but it was better than i
expected it to be i like some of the phasing of
even just consciou on the ground level of how he
moved there uh so yeah i like when like they go
on giant and you know there's that slow motion
and they swoop the feel the scale yeah i love
them when they swim the car was so tiny that was
one of my favorite shots well that was a good uh
establisher that like oh yeah these are physical
forms and they are wreaking havoc over here
yeah yeah i thought that was really great layla
i like the acoustic version better
from uh eric clapton unplugged more
than um the actual rock and roll edition wow
that's right he's an artist i'm an artist
because i've named one of the two eric clapton
um so yeah i thought layla's uh costume
was great and um full disclosure
but if you guys know who the character is from
a comic book please let us know uh which would
be very interesting for the mcu to have like a
a like a a another female hero we don't have too
many lady heroes in the mcu girls get it done an
egyptian hero and if it's going to be completely
original and i honestly i think it is and i
feel like this is a really cool way to start
introducing new heroes in this direction like
harley quinn came through and the animated series
and then became a comic book so like having a tv
show introduces through women through through the
tv show comic book artists don't like writing
females but i i feel like that's a really like
smart way for the mcu to start to be unique
from the comics yeah yeah very true i thought
her powers were really cool it was wonder woman
ask sure um at the same time it still felt like
it's its own thing i like the use of the flight
the wings um i i was a bit concerned that it was
going to be inside once i said that and then i saw
where my thoughts were going and then i heard what
some of the comments might say and i'm going to
stop there i'm going to say this instead oh no
i'm going to say what i'm saying i'm going to stop
you from saying what you're probably going to say
some of you for people out there was that i was
concerned that it was going to be layla was going
to save the whole day and now i know a lot of
people might go oh freaking woke agenda somewhere
yeah and i didn't that's not where i was going
with i just thought about i might undercut the
show a little bit uh just for the fact that your
title character is not the one who's the hero or
like actually saves the day but that's something
i did like about this as well like it gave us the
the arc of the character fully stephen and mark
coming together embracing each other as brothers
and learning to literally just live during the
day like with each other they just they know
how to alternate back and forth it kind of kind of
happened a little quick to me and so that one more
episode i really would love it it should have
been two episodes like if you if you play the
episodes back to back of five and six stephen's
gone for like 15 minutes that's it as opposed to
like having the reeds having the breakdown having
the bond having the development of the two voices
having all of that take longer have the psychology
back in the psych ward have that developed have
the harrow stuff last a little bit longer have the
fight work in the same way probably the same pace
but just letting the moments breathe other than
the fights i feel like the fight was the right
amount of time i feel like the fight especially
the switching between mr night and moon night
was so special because it was so rapidly between
the two if it was longer it wouldn't have felt
special as long and then juxtaposing the small
contained fight with the kaiju fight was really
cool visually so i loved all that but whenever
it wasn't fighting i did feel like they were
like we gotta get back to the fighting and i
was like but there's so much psychology that we
were resolving here yeah i didn't feel much uh i
wasn't really hooked like nothing was really like
latching into my emotions during this episode you
know and the rest of the series i have them other
than the probably you know the part when they
do actually bond with each other i mean uh where
mark does rescue stephen in the sand well yeah
i was going to say this was and then this isn't
to spoil multiverse madness i had a similar kind
of complaint about that movie was that this kept
giving me these scenes where i was like this is so
wonderful like i love that back and forth between
stephen and mark or even the back and forth
between layla and konchu i thought was great where
she's like i'm not gonna be your slave like there
are all these moments that hint at some really
great character unpacking and even for harrow
i think he got slighted maybe the most in this
episode because i again have been loving ethan
hawk's performance and he makes that ultimate
sacrifice and there are all those moments where
he's like hey i i have dedicated my life to you
but you know what if my scales aren't uh balanced
i accept my fate like i loved those bits and then
you know he becomes amit's avatar and then pretty
much from there it's just like well okay so we
gotta bind her to him and there's the physical
stakes and as long as we can kill them we'll be
good and uh yeah it was one of those things where
i feel like it's all there it just could have been
more graceful and it could have come down to more
than just the plotting yeah i still feel like it
got a little too big for my tastes too big too
too quickly yeah yeah cause like ahmet uh for some
reason just doesn't leave much of an impression
to on me and what and why does her avatar not get
a cool outfit i don't know she's just gonna stay
in the same ropes at first when she showed up i
was like interesting and then she started talking
and i was like yeah that i feel like this build up
to ahmed being unleashed really wasn't anything
special i i didn't other than like cool visual
of giant konchu and giant ahmet the character
of amen and the build-up to ultimately what she
was doing i really think this needed to be two
episodes it really would have changed everything
it didn't drop my stomach the way i wanted it to
yeah no nor what did it feel as it didn't start
feeling actually scary or menacing until she was
like we're judging everyone in egypt right now
a bunch of moments that were cool like that like
there were a bunch of moments where we got excited
that like i i want to give the the episode a
lot more credit for those things that did work
it's just the major major thing of wishing it
was more length is is i the undercurrent like
we can say we love you know the emotional ties of
seeing that giant rapture we can say we enjoyed
the emotional connection between them two and
the fights and all those things but without the
time between those moments it did feel like that's
all we can talk about well yeah it's like there's
there's moments and then there's scenes there's
like there's a big difference between them and
i think that a lot of the the actual scenes were
just not having the effect that i think they were
intending that that were desired you know like
there's a lot i feel like you could pick a part
here and there's a lot i think you can isolate
and look back on and go well i appreciate that
like you brought up the scene for
podcast listeners john brought up
the scene because that's me about uh you know
like when konchu is is debating with layla
i do like that reveal though of kancho
being like i never wanted that girl
yeah that was nice the jake reveal i don't i think
this might be one of the first times we had the
show end in a post-credits scene we were talking
that this isn't like a continuation into the
future and further it is obviously setting up
things but it's also kind of the end of the
show and it's interesting to do that after some
credits and i don't know if i've seen that well
i think what's neat about that reveal i know we're
kind of hopping around all over the place here but
that you know that's kind of the vibe that's left
here uh is that konchu is he has a negotiation
with mark and um stephen you know and then it
makes mark and steven feel like they're finally
in control of the situation with konchu and
then the ending reveal shows you no they're not
they're not and they probably have never been in
control and they're not even aware of it there's
only like teas like by now they should be like
there's a third personality in me they have to at
least somewhat deduce that they haven't even said
that to themselves this is the second time maybe
that's the defense mechanism like maybe they're
blocking that much yeah yeah i mean you get it
here in that one bit of like that definitely
wasn't me that wasn't me i do like that he spent
he speak he's a spanish-speaking character because
uh you know oscar isaac being cuban in guatemala
and totally did not look that up in between
setting up microphones uh him being cube in
guatemalan and being able to represent that here
is awesome also the ability that he has to go
between languages and accents in the same sentence
is staggering some of the acting in this obviously
the whole show we've been praising the acting but
every time he transfers in between moments and in
this one now that he's doing it in real time like
he's actually both steven and mark live at us
incredible work like truly staggering yeah
definitely how do you guys feel about hero
overall as a villain throughout the series i think
it felt like ethan hawk personally his character i
really liked him more in the psych ward more
than i did as actually arthur harrow i like what
he represented inside of mark and steven's mind
more but i know you really yeah i clicked on him
a lot throughout this series so curious to know
like how you feel about arthur harrow in total
yeah i mean mvp in term one of the mvps in terms
of performance i mean like you know all the
flowers to oscar isaac absolutely but i really
do love what ethan hawk has brought to this and
and again i liked the notes with him that carried
through this but i i gotta kind of agree with you
that the most interesting and and part of the
interesting thing about the way he is the doctor
in you know the the the you know mental asylum
you know sort of spiritual way station is based
on your association with him on earth but yeah i i
feel like that is the most interesting stuff when
it comes right down to it and i kept wishing
that there was again more time to explore him
personally because there's so much really
interesting connective tissue between him and
mark steve and jake etc his relation to khanshu
and everything and you know he gets kind of a
raw deal with with amit and i would have liked
to have i don't know it's it's it's interesting
it's a badass and very kind of cold-blooded
ending that they give to him but it's like oh
he's dead now i guess that's that i don't really
like that cliche anymore where character kills
people constantly and then when it comes down
to the big baddie they become a moral hero and
and i especially didn't like it here
because that was ridiculously rushed
he's been killing so many people like he is
constantly in this episode alone he's like
steps but until the guy that's trying to kill
the planet yeah no he's still well and yeah and
the fact that there's so much of the conflict
between stephen and mark is steven going dude
you're a savage you killing cold blood we can't do
that anymore like that's cool that's fine except
this episode also then goes to swap that round
and go well mark's actually not that much of a
savage the stephen lockley he's the savage so it
kind of muddies that up too that scene felt very
perfunctory to me in the way that was handled and
it just was just like get the get the lines out
of the way that's how it like read to me in the
moment just so quick and especially after we had
just had this really cool moment of introducing
a new hero and having this really cool like
power couple moment to have that undermined by
this very traditional oh this is a hero moment
it felt like oh we're subverting expectations
and expectations and and that the rest of the
show hadn't felt that way for me that's very
good point because i personally really liked how
you know jake lockley you don't see him take
out all the bad guys you don't see although it
might have been cool to do one of those like fight
club montages where you like go back and you see
speaking spanish in the because i told you
when he popped in the cab and he was like
what's that accent i would love to see him
speaking spanish i'm killing five people
it's the el mariachi there's like a
whole robert rodriguez movie that happens
yeah that's episode eight at once borrowing from
boba fett i didn't i i didn't uh didn't care for
that scene um but because you could have come
down to something interesting between the two
avatars and between again somebody who has known
khan shu's service but also now under ahmet
service like you could have made an interesting
conflict that also plays off of or bounces off of
what is literally gigantically happening backdrop
harrow didn't get the chance to really manifest
his being the official avatar nor did we really
have the actual conflict of the avatars greeting
ethan because they got killed off camera so like
you've set up this thing where ethan hawk has been
forgiven inexplicably because he lost grizzlies
like yo he's doing some stuff they're like we
don't believe you oscar isaac and then he marches
in they're like oh i guess he was right dead off
screen i would have liked to have had some more
there to me the biggest disappointment of all this
the biggest disappointment is that it did exactly
what i was worried this finale would do which was
be go big have a lot of action but we had five
episodes prior even the third episode which i
personally thought a lot of people loved that
episode i thought that was the weakest of the
of the five i really felt like the
thing they dropped the ball on the most
was they dropped everything about conversations
psychology and they just went for big you know
they had that one great scene where you do see you
know mark and steven entering back into their own
mind working together beautiful defeat you know
like overcoming the manipulative the psychiatrist
therapist uh in their own mind i thought that was
a really great acceptance scene uh as on top of
it all that was a really good one but like all
the they had such good debates and conversations
and and philosophical existential conversations
woven in throughout this series in so many ways
and like discussions uh even with arthur harrow
with layla with mark with stephen and then
the gods debated in episode three at least you
know discussing this and then here it's just like
zip zip bang bang bang you know to me that's
my one division problem is i really really
loved wanda vision and there was literally a
transition from ship of theseus to punch vision
yeah it goes very quickly episode six felt like
the marvel episode and i like marvel but if you're
gonna let me have something that's a psychological
and philosophical conversation and then suddenly
pivot to punching that's not the show and like to
me that was if this could have kept the punching
but also kept the psychology if there was
one more episode that's that's the balance
they gotta strike and that's why this had to have
been two episodes and i don't think every show was
success loki six episodes yeah it is yeah wow it's
i think it's a structure issue and one division is
eight yep they're shorter that's true well they
grow because yeah they start out being like 30
25 30 minutes and they become like 45 50 55.
and i really think that like you need like that
flexibility worked and i think moon knight could
have used a little bit of that like let this be
seven this felt like studio notes in a lot of way
of like we got to go back it was still a superhero
show so you know let's let's get a little bit
more lively here you know like with the whole
thing when they're the the stakes of when stephen
and mark are reunited and they're walking back to
to get out and there were still so many cool
things but yeah it's just like that's the thing
and then the the cyrus the boat and then the
freaking yeah i'm gonna stop the waves like
this kind of it starts to feel a little like a
disney movie yeah yeah yeah yeah it's silly so
yeah and it's also and if koi's having issues you
know this you know what you guys i'm trying to be
before i turn into steven um so yeah you know it's
like last episode a lot of these episodes just
like are so invigorating that no matter how tired
i am they just spark a thought process and here
i'm just like my feelings i'm left with are some
of the coolest moments like the action was really
cool like that was really getting me a lot of the
time and and it was also that feeling too of like
i really want to keep loving this so
i'm really trying to give in to the
the cool even more but then by the time it wraps
up i'm but it literally was the scene when uh mark
is like i'm not gonna kill him you do it you know
at that moment was when i was like okay yeah this
this has totally lost me at that moment for my
for me like the the problem was how good the
rest of the show was that i my expectations
were at that consistent a that like high
concept a really interesting thought-provoking
situation and then for the last episode
to be you know a b b minus it's not bad it's not
you know uh it's just bel the average show is
not even a b for me but the average of this
has been an a so a b feels like a downgrade
so comparatively is the problem and that's what's
hard about these six episode shows is if you've
got this momentum with five and then six doesn't
stick the landing it affects your whole experience
and i do think there could have been a bit
of a different way to handle the what was ref
what was left of the story to tell especially
after that remarkable fifth five man well because
it makes the fifth episode then feel like it's out
of a separate show and got dropped into this more
sort of fun and swashbuckling thing and if
we could have had that because i feel like
five in generals stands separate from all of
them because they all have a certain reliance
on adventure and we got to keep things moving
and stuff and we're building the psychology and
they're all crescendos there and it doesn't feel
like we gracefully came out of that crescendo into
this you know it feels like we started in one show
we had that fifth episode to really kind of flood
it with this saturation of emotion and then the
last one kind of ends up somewhere in the middle
kind of like floating in the middle of those
things i'm curious re-watching it now that i
have the expectations of the last episode being so
action-packed if it would be feel better now that
you know like now that i know that's the route
if the whole show you know knowing where it lands
feels better i just don't think you can get back
to light to lighter without feeling a little bit
of of that kind of without feeling the difference
in the weight you know because this does just
feel like a lighter thing at the end and there is
something too about that that i think narrows the
scope or makes the scope again feel a little
bit more like a cartoon and i think you know
in reveling in some of those harsher darker more
challenging emotions you can then help legitimize
all of the crazy magical circumstances around
you but the faster the circumstances have to
unfold the more everything starts to feel like
a rollercoaster ride yeah i like what you just
said about lighter and darker i wish we had a
couple moments to like appreciate the fact that
that so many people were dying in the streets
of egypt and we were seeing these people like
judging each other and they were seeing like this
massive horrific event and it was like 30 seconds
like we didn't get time to realize how traumatic
that was we didn't get time to realize like these
people are judging their neighbor and killing
them and that's all happening and that we've
set up the whole show to that like that this is
the revelations we were like waiting for ahmed to
come back for then i was like we gotta get back to
the fight and i just i wanted to live there more
that's i just keep i sound like a broken record i
just want more and i love that this is my problem
but like i want more yeah yeah well here we are
again another marvel from now good moments some
great moments in the finale a lot of great moments
overall where you guys ranked the shows oh boy
um i like ranking stuff i'm a list guy
i'm a virgo how many shows we got now
low-key
i'd still give the edge to moon knight falcon
this one yeah you got two left yeah there it is
yeah i was letting you get there then episode four
of what if of doctor strange and then what if
that's one little category it would probably be
loki one division this and falcon of winter
soldier can grapple for the next slot then uh what
if hawkeye so this is a little slightly above for
me it goes loki this one division for me but those
three are like this beautiful like different you
know top category and then falcon winter soldier
hawkeye what if man this is tough because
this one i really i don't know why
i feel especially as much as there were like
some really cool exciting moments it's one
of those things that the more i think about it
the more i feel like i'm in the sand just like
yeah oh i'm feeling empty and cold because i
think it hurts more when the show proves it can
sing and it can be so great and then it doesn't
yeah so when we talk about it i'm like oh i'm
i'm withering away and i'm over here going like i
like that moon night mr knight fight and i really
like the dichotomy between the sizes and i really
like the moment where their brothers and bonded
again and i'm gonna stay in the happy space i'm
going i'm over here like you know somewhere out
there there's a timeline where this was incredible
somewhere there's a timeline where there's seven
episodes so that was very exciting seven episodes
every show on the seven episode timeline there's
a multiverse koi very excited about the seventh
episode of moon night yeah yeah all right well
what did you guys at least had fun at
the time i was watching it with you guys
yeah that's what i'll say i'll leave it
there it was fun at the time of watching it
and the less i talk about it the more i can
just appreciate the enjoyment i had i wasn't
bored the real fist of conscious the friends
we made along the way you see the only real
problem i'd have is if i was bored but i wasn't
bored so if i'm not bored then all right fine
i would rather want more of what we're
seeing which i do than want less of
what we're seeing which i don't i would
absolutely be excited for a season two
100 yeah i think we can all agree there the
imagination and the tonal expansion alone
is is worth the effort i'd also love to see him
pop into other different tones and how weird it
would be if moon knight was just suddenly like
hanging out spiderman and deadpool sharon have
you earned this mics we're talking way longer
than usual definitely good luck at it we like
our choices here we are [__] for you guys you
got no editing oh you don't wanna settle yeah
guys bye love you all bye everyone bye everyone